[Music]
Kalas ons are a traditional French candy
made of almonds candied melon and orange
peel topped with a thin layer of hard
typically white icing chalice ons are
the specialty of the city of aches on
Provence in the Provence region of
southern France the callosum was created
in France in the mid 15th century in
honor of the wedding of King rené of
Anjou and Queen John of Laval the
confection became the specialty of
Provence the region of southern France
known for its almond orchards inside the
greenish Hall is a hard shell inside
that shell is the edible almond seed the
almonds arrived at the workshop tried
for conservation and they're brown skin
removed the first step in the production
is to rehydrate the almonds with steam
for about 10 minutes so that they can be
worked into a paste once the almonds
moisture content is increased by two to
four percent the almonds pass over a
vibrating screen to drain any water
resulting from steam condensation
meanwhile this cauldron heats up liquid
beet sugar France is one of the world's
largest sugar beet producers so high
quality beet sugar is readily available
workers transfer the hydrated almonds to
a grinder and add candied fruit 95%
melon and 5% orange peel this flavor is
the 500 year old traditional recipe
workers grind the ingredients for about
10 minutes until everything is
thoroughly blended into a coarse paste
the pace drops onto a conveyer belt
which transfers it to a kneading machine
into which workers add the hot liquid
beet sugar and natural almond oil made
from bitter almonds kneading blends the
ingredients and smoothes the texture of
the paste a worker boxes the callous on
paste and sets it aside for three days
to let the sugar mature and stabilize
Kalas ons are topped with an ever so
thin layer of royal icing
unlike creamy icings royal icing is as
hard as a rock to make it a worker
combines icing sugar and whipped egg
whites passed through a strainer a mixer
beats the ingredients until the mixture
is thick and smooth which typically
takes about 10 minutes
[Music]
after three days of rest the paste is
ready to be worked shaping and
decorating the callus ons as a
specialized task entrusted to these
experienced artisans call Kelly Sun
Aires first they place slices of paste
in a press and load a mold underneath
they cover the mold with a wafer thin
sheet of unleavened bread then the press
piston descends forcing the paste with
the bread layer underneath into the mold
they skim off the excess paste then fold
the stencil over the mold and apply the
layer of royal icing
they lift off the stencil and push the
buttons which activate the mold pistons
each piston pierces the base of a callus
on and lifts it out of the mold
finally they remove the callous ons with
combs designed to fit around the Pistons
a ten-minute trip through a tunnel oven
set at low temperature bakes the royal
icing to a hard and shiny state
cameras record the position of the
callous ons as they exit the oven
guiding a robotic arm to pick up 160 per
minute and place them in plastic trays
the next machine seals each tray with
plastic film to preserve freshness
there's also a gift box format for which
a worker hand fills plastic trays
designed to fit Lawson shaped metal
boxes these traditional Cala Suns
contain a candied fruit content of at
least 30% the melon being a variety
cultivated in the region of Provence
[Music]
however if your taste buds are the type
that bucked tradition today you can
enjoy a wide selection of other
fashionable flavors such as Clementine
and coca bean or raspberry and matcha
green-tea
you